what i want to do in this video is
explore the idea
of allele frequency
allele frequency and just as a reminder
an allele is a variant of a gene
you get a variant of the g of a gene
from your mother and you get another
variant of the gene from the father and
so when we're talking about the allele
we're talking about that specific
variant that you got from your mother or
your father and we've seen this before
but now let's dig a little bit deeper
and to to help us get our heads around
this we'll we'll start with a a fairly
common a fairly common model for this
and we're going to think about eye color
and obviously this is a very large
simplification but let's just assume
that we're we have a population where
there's only two variants of an eye
color gene let's first assume there is
an eye color gene and assume there's two
variants
one variant one allele for for eye color
we'll we'll use the shorthand capital b
let's say that's the allele for brown
brown eye color and we're going to
assume that this one is dominant it's
dominant over the other allele
now the other allele we're going to
assume is for blue eye color and we'll
represent that with a lowercase b
so that is blue eye color and we're
going to assume we're going to assume
that this is recessive so once again
this is review someone who has one of
the big
b alleles the brown alleles it doesn't
matter what their other allele is going
to be because it's either going to be
another brown or it's going to be a blue
they're going to where they're going to
show brown eyes so this is going to be
brown eyes
and this is going to be brown eyes
because the capital b is dominant the
only way to get blue eyes is to be the
only way to have blue eyes is to be a
homozygote for the recessive for the
recessive allele and all of that of
course is review we've seen that before
but now let's think about allele
frequency and to think about that i'll
set up a very
artificially small population so let's
say our population
has exactly two people in it
population has exactly two people in it
person one and person two
and let's say we're able to look into
their dna and figure out their genotypes
so person one
let's say
has a capital b allele has a brown
allele and a blue allele while person
two has two
blue
two blue alleles
now given that we know the genotypes in
this artificially small population now
we can start thinking about the allele
frequencies or the frequencies of the
different alleles
so what do you think is going to be the
frequency the frequency of
the brown allele in this population and
i encourage you to pause this video and
think about this on your own
so i'm assuming you've had a go at it so
you might be tempted to say oh it looks
like one out of two people have it maybe
it's 50 percent but that wouldn't be the
right way to think about allele
frequencies and allele frequencies you
want to dig a little bit deeper and look
at the individual alleles when you look
at that you say okay there's four
individual alleles in this population of
or there's four variants in this or this
there's literally four chromosomes i
guess you could say that they're
carrying that gene in this population
and out of them one of them carry
one of them is the capital b
is the capital b allele
and so we could say that that is going
to be 0.25
or 25 percent so once again
of the genes for eye color have the
capital b allele have the brown allele
now we can do the same we can ask
ourselves the same question for the
lowercase b allele what fraction of the
of the genes in this population
are
code for or
represent the lowercase b the blue
allele and once again i encourage you to
pause the video and think about it
well very similar idea there's four
there's four there's four genes in the
population that are coding for eye color
of them one two three
1 2 3 code 4 or are the lower case blue
are the lower case blue allele so that's
0.75
or
75 percent 75 of the genes code for the
lower case
the blue allele while 25 are the brown
are the brown allele and i really want
to hit this point home how this is
different than say the phenotype
frequency if i if i asked you in the
population
if i asked you
the percent
of
brown eyed people
brown eyed people so now i'm
now i'm talking about phenotype what
would that be
well there's two people in the
population one of them is exhibiting
brown eyes so that's going to be one
half and similarly similarly
if i were to ask you what is the
percentage of people who are blue eyed
that two would be one half this person
is one of the two people they're
exhibiting blue eyes but allele
frequency we're digging deeper we're
looking at the genotypes and we're
saying well out of the four
out of the four genes here
one of them is the big b allele so
that's 25 percent of so 25 percent of
the of the of the gene population codes
for is the brown allele and 75
is the blue allele and this is really
important to internalize because once we
internalize this then as we'll see that
the ideas in the hardy weinberg
principle start to make a lot of sense
and i'll do a little bit of
foreshadowing we can denote
we can denote this this is just a
convention that's often used by the
lowercase letter p
and we can use
q lowercase q to denote the frequency so
p lowercase p is the frequency of the
dominant allele lowercase q the
frequency of the recessive allele but
what's true here what's true of p
what's true what's going to be true of p
plus q
what's going to be what's p plus q going
to be equal to and i encourage you to
pause the video again and think about
that what is this what is this going to
be equal to
well when we started off we said that
there's only two potential that's one of
the assumptions we assumed we assume
there's only two alleles in this
population and then kind of the allele
population for this and the gene
population for this trait
so the frequency of the of the dominant
ones plus the frequency of the recessive
ones well everyone's going to have one
of those two so there if you add those
two frequencies it's going to have to
add to
100 percent we see that there one-fourth
plus three-fourths is one is one or
one-hundred percent
and twenty-five percent plus 75 percent
is also 100 so we could say p plus q is
equal to 100 percent or we could say
that p
plus q
is
equal to one
is equal to one and so the next video
we're going to start from the seemingly
fairly simple idea to get to a more a
richer and fairly neat idea that's
expressed in the hardy weinberg equation